not only did he view himself as a
prophet but indeed as the very Messiah
who would eventually be revealed and end
the Dominion of Christianity to
reinstate the glory of the True Religion
he taught maimonides his Guide to the
perplexed in places like Italy and
started to develop his own very unique
form of Kabbalah in his writings and the
teachings that he presented to some of
his students at the time he presents a
version of Kabbalah that is quite
different from the theosophical version
of the Zohar abulafia's main focus was
on the Divine names the letters of the
Hebrew alphabets and various meditative
techniques that would help the
practitioner reach an ecstatic mystical
experience of Union with the active
intellect and ultimately with God
himself